[SPEAKER_03]: The evening of the Second of Wealsun, after the battle at the Southern Garrison, the sun begins to dip over the mountains to the west.
[SPEAKER_03]: Have I had any recovery time?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gouge decides for a short rest as do all the men in the unit.
[SPEAKER_03]: So basically if you're wounded, roll your dice if you want to do that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, at how many for a short rest?
[SPEAKER_03]: You can roll as many of those six that you want, but remember you can only do three short rests and if you use all six die in the first one,
[SPEAKER_03]: You have none left for the rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: Until tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_03]: Until a long rest happens.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you're going to do two.
[SPEAKER_03]: Start with two.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, roll those.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eight and a four plus four for your constitution bonus.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that's 12, 16 you get back.
[SPEAKER_00]: 12 plus four because you rolled two guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep, plus four.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so 12, 16.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're right.
[SPEAKER_01]: These men that are hurt, can I roll for them?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: And let's see about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: How's this one?
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably bad too.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I got 16?
[SPEAKER_03]: So there's...
[SPEAKER_03]: There's one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight men that are wounded.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight men that are wounded?
[SPEAKER_03]: And they get one die eight.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, one die ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: One die ten?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So... Is it a clear night?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's going to be a clear night.
[SPEAKER_03]: What kind of moon?
[SPEAKER_03]: Actually, it is going to be a...
[SPEAKER_03]: It's going to be pretty dark, actually.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to roll one more, so I'm going to use three of my six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eight, that is ten more that you get back.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you use three, so mark that.
[SPEAKER_02]: While our short rest was happening, did anything else happen with Paul Reb?
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm going to say...
[SPEAKER_00]: Three used.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm only down two hit points.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, good.
[SPEAKER_03]: So now... Well, you didn't see anything else happen, but we'll get to that after we do the short rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, four of them?
[SPEAKER_03]: The first four.
[SPEAKER_01]: First four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Pick a die.
[SPEAKER_03]: First one gets six.
[SPEAKER_03]: He is healed.
[SPEAKER_03]: Next one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gets four.
[SPEAKER_03]: He has one off him.
[SPEAKER_03]: The old character that we used to use.
[SPEAKER_03]: The next one gets two.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's still got ten off him.
[SPEAKER_03]: The first one is ten.
[SPEAKER_03]: Make a little counter.
[SPEAKER_01]: The next one is six.
[SPEAKER_01]: He has four off him.
[SPEAKER_01]: The next one is nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is healed.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so my guys are getting good.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so there's two guys that still are a little bad off.
[SPEAKER_03]: One has 60 points off them and the other one has 10 that maybe should not go into trouble.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do we put them out of their misery or we let them keep healing or we'd use them as goats out in front for if we're going to do something?
[SPEAKER_00]: So if we got to sacrifice a couple, it's those two.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can I check?
[SPEAKER_04]: I want them just one eye.
[SPEAKER_04]: We don't want him to go down.
[SPEAKER_04]: We got corpses up where I was shooting to see if I can get any arrows back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: In fact, roll a survival roll to see how many of your arrows you can get back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tell me what you roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: I got an 18 plus 6.
[SPEAKER_04]: You get all your arrows back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, you guys was talking with Merrick there.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's very familiar with the island.
[SPEAKER_00]: We should be okay staying on high ground off the beaches from the shark things.
[SPEAKER_00]: Depends on what the moon is tonight.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know who knows what that is, but these other creatures, the hobgoblins at the barracks, probably have InfraVision, but I don't think their distance will work, and if we got any type of moonlight it'll be ineffective.
[SPEAKER_00]: So at night we should be able to move fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're thinking about making the move at night.
[SPEAKER_00]: The island should be clear of any type of creatures because this is not a big island and should have been cleared from what he said.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what our guess is on the knowledge that anything here would be dead or hunted.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I know anything else today?
[SPEAKER_03]: You know that there's really no creatures that live on the island.
[SPEAKER_00]: Birds, mainly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Rats, fucking tree baboons or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe.
[SPEAKER_00]: They'd be picked off for fun.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do I know of any other storage tunnels or anything on the island?
[SPEAKER_04]: We need to get a small party to go.
[SPEAKER_03]: You've heard that there are sea caves underneath the helm that actually lead into the structure.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, the helm, the big structure.
[SPEAKER_03]: Their location is a secret.
[SPEAKER_04]: You just know that that's a thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: And they're off the coast.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, it's probably...
[SPEAKER_00]: Sending Merrick ahead, me on his back for protection in case he does come across something.
[SPEAKER_00]: Bart, do you have any spells left?
[SPEAKER_00]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I gotta check that short rest for Paladin.
[SPEAKER_00]: And keep the group tagging behind with somebody on the back end watching our tail.
[SPEAKER_03]: The sergeant says, we do have to make a plan, but...
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm scared of exposing the men to dangers out of this fortification if we don't know what's safe.
[SPEAKER_03]: So what I'm thinking is that we send Merrick forward to scout the island.
[SPEAKER_03]: He knows it better than anyone.
[SPEAKER_03]: He can slip through the darkness and find whether or not the barracks are taken by our enemies or not.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't like letting him go alone.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I want to go with him.
[SPEAKER_04]: We both can move pretty well in the darkness.
[SPEAKER_04]: He'll follow behind me and have my back if we have any issues.
[SPEAKER_04]: If we can get to the barracks and it is clear... How are you going to let us know?
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you have a tinderbox?
[SPEAKER_04]: I do.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do I as well with the explorer pack?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to light an arrow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that's going to give away your position.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I think if we can get to the barracks and stay on that wall down low, we should be able to spark a small enough light that you guys can see from there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now the other hobgoblins can see it as well, but it's not like they're going to be able to do anything about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: If they leave, they'll expose themselves and you guys can pick them up and take care of them.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if we can get all the way to that wall,
[SPEAKER_00]: Light something means come forward.
[SPEAKER_00]: Light two things means we're coming back.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll figure out what that is.
[SPEAKER_03]: One of the archers comes in and goes, Sir, we're getting a strange signal from the barracks.
[SPEAKER_04]: Bar, do you recognize the signal?
[SPEAKER_04]: What kind of signal is it?
[SPEAKER_04]: It's like a light signal.
[SPEAKER_03]: Much like Morse code.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you think he would understand if he knew codes?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh yeah, he would.
[SPEAKER_02]: K. K. K. No, you can read it.
[SPEAKER_02]: K. A.
[SPEAKER_02]: Write it down.
[SPEAKER_02]: K. K. No.
[SPEAKER_02]: K-A-R-M-I-R-G. Carmary.
[SPEAKER_02]: It repeats again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just keep saying Karm, over and over again.
[SPEAKER_02]: K-A-R. Can you signal back?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can you signal back?
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want me to signal back?
[SPEAKER_00]: Does he have the ability to signal back with anything?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, you guys have signaling devices that work at night.
[SPEAKER_03]: They don't work during the day.
[SPEAKER_02]: Signal back.
[SPEAKER_02]: G-O-U-G-E.
[SPEAKER_02]: And wait.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's it?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's it.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's that mean?
[SPEAKER_02]: You get a signal back.
[SPEAKER_02]: J-U-D-E. Shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um... Um...
[SPEAKER_02]: Signal back.
[SPEAKER_02]: U, O, K. Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: S, A, M, E. The signaling goes on and the communication basically is
[SPEAKER_03]: The barracks is in the hands of the Monmurian Navy.
[SPEAKER_03]: There are 150 Marines there that are safe.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, the helm has been taken.
[SPEAKER_03]: Paul Ribeiro, you ask about this, Paul Ribeiro is in the barracks.
[SPEAKER_03]: The end signal is, come as soon as possible.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't want to take the full party there.
[SPEAKER_04]: They've got 150.
[SPEAKER_00]: We've got 30 people.
[SPEAKER_00]: Signal back tonight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait for a reply.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're waiting.
[SPEAKER_02]: Waiting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so it's safe to get to the barracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can we get a long rest in?
[SPEAKER_01]: How long would be a long rest?
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight hours.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have to move now.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have to move to them.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not far and take a long rest with them if they have the barracks and they're safe.
[SPEAKER_03]: We have wounded.
[SPEAKER_03]: What about the enemy?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think the enemy is going to be able to do anything at night.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have the bridge here.
[SPEAKER_04]: They have that.
[SPEAKER_04]: We need to keep this tower occupied with at least some troops and archers to keep it occupied.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't want to leave the whole south part of this thing for them to take over again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Our whole backside.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: But this doesn't really help us.
[SPEAKER_03]: It does help us.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm actually, Tyrus, I think it does help us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Prince John sends another ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can signal from here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And warn them.
[SPEAKER_01]: It will at least tie up the enemies that we have here.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not going to be able to advance behind us, I guess, huh?
[SPEAKER_03]: And not only that, we'll be able to cover them if they try to come behind you.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, I assume, Merrick, that you need to get to the barracks.
[SPEAKER_04]: I wouldn't take leave.
[SPEAKER_04]: Aristotle's, or, what's your real name?
[SPEAKER_04]: What do you go by?
[SPEAKER_04]: It's getting really annoying.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I know Jude and I know Carmer that are there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So my cover's blown for whatever it is, but don't refer to me as that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, got it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, so... At this point in time.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so I'm gonna...
[SPEAKER_04]: As soon as we can with Nightfall, I'm gonna take lead with Aristotle's closely behind me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you can call me Gouge amongst yourselves here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, we need to get, uh, what was your name?
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus and Folsom, you're gonna come with us after we give you the okay, a signal saying that it's okay to clear this certain amount of area.
[SPEAKER_04]: Does it lead the sergeant to be able to hold this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Does the sergeant want to go with us?
[SPEAKER_04]: I think the sergeant needs to hold it.
[SPEAKER_03]: They need some sort of...
[SPEAKER_03]: If you can sneak through the darkness of night, we'll cover you and make sure the hobgoblins don't come from behind.
[SPEAKER_03]: Done.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hopefully the path will be clear enough.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, stay off the beaches and stay off the quays.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because the hogging are out there and they are very active at night.
[SPEAKER_00]: Be careful when you cross the bridge.
[SPEAKER_00]: None of us have night vision.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know if it works, it depends on the moonlight anyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: What about them, do they?
[SPEAKER_00]: Those creatures?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: We need to take at least two archers, two marines to escort.
[SPEAKER_04]: Need a couple bodies.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just in case shit hits the fan.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can give up five men.
[SPEAKER_03]: The ones that are not wounded, the wounded will stay here with me and heal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're going to take two archers.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sergeant, no signaling.
[SPEAKER_03]: Two crossbow men.
[SPEAKER_03]: Three Marines.
[SPEAKER_03]: He'll be your signal man.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know how to signal.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can communicate.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you take two shield men with you as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Two archers, two shield men?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Take four guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: So your party will be eight.
[SPEAKER_03]: That should be enough for you to make it there safely if you're going in stealth.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we're taking one eye, who obviously is not an archer because he does not have the depth.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: But he is good.
[SPEAKER_00]: He is strong.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Definitely taking one eye.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so we're taking one eye.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: One thumb is too wounded for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think he died.
[SPEAKER_01]: He did die.
[SPEAKER_01]: One thumb died.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he has too wounded.
[SPEAKER_00]: We want one eye on the swordsman.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's going to leave a total of...
[SPEAKER_01]: There was eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's 22 men here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, but eight of them are archers and the rest are... No, we're taking two of the archers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, so there was ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, there was ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: None of them died.
[SPEAKER_01]: None of the archers died.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then that's gonna leave...
[SPEAKER_01]: So you are two of the archers, so it's gonna leave six archers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, six archers there, pardon me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six archers there.
[SPEAKER_01]: South Tower...
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six archers.
[SPEAKER_03]: I thought I was scouting.
[SPEAKER_01]: You didn't count.
[SPEAKER_01]: But these two were considered archers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: We had 19...
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I counted as one of the...
[SPEAKER_01]: I counted as one, he counted as one.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you're taking two of those guys and three of them died, so there will be fifteen men left.
[SPEAKER_03]: The captain and six archers.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fifteen swordsmen?
[SPEAKER_00]: Fifteen swordsmen left.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six archers and the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_01]: One serge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who can signal?
[SPEAKER_03]: The sergeant can signal.
[SPEAKER_01]: We should also tell the sergeant...
[SPEAKER_01]: That if any other ships come by...
[SPEAKER_01]: He's going to wave them off.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's going to have to wave them off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless they're reinforcements.
[SPEAKER_03]: If another ship comes up, he's basically going to wave them off and say this is a full-scale attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, there's too many sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_04]: If they hit here, they should be overrun like those were.
[SPEAKER_04]: We got lucky.
[SPEAKER_04]: And with all the amount of sharks that I saw in the water pulling up, I'm assuming those are sahaugin that were in the water.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sahaugin communicate with sharks telepathically, and they are their slaves.
[SPEAKER_03]: So they get swarms of sharks to attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: The waters around here are not even safe for the biggest of boats to come near us.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're going to get swarmed and overran.
[SPEAKER_04]: You need to just throw them off as fast as you can.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now what are you good on time frame with your phone call?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are we going to proceed on the next thing, or are you calling it?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think what we do is we do loot and we do experience points.
[SPEAKER_03]: We roll up hit points for people that have gone up a level and then we call it a knife.
[SPEAKER_03]: Does that sound okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: I could be here for the next two years.